foreign
welcome to the show
hi thank you for taking my call thanks
for calling how can we help
um just uh well I retired a couple years
ago and so I'm like one half the income
that I usually have and my husband is
still working he's younger than me he's
probably got another
10 years while he'll be working we have
a 401k I have a paid retirement benefit
but I had a little bit in a 401k so I
already invested it and I just kind of
want to forget about it and let it do
its thing for a while
but in the meantime we have um debt and
um I've kind of been living off my car
just because we go paycheck to paycheck
and um I'm trying to put together a
budget and there's just a couple things
we had like a eight thousand dollars put
aside for Home Improvements but it's
been sitting there from an old refi a
couple years ago and since we're not
using it I wanted to put it towards my
card
um and get my balance down but uh then
he mentioned well we're going to need to
pay taxes and it might be around that
amount too so now I'm not sure if I
should use it to get my card down or if
I should see what we owe in taxes and
maybe use it for that okay but with such
high interest on the cards I I figure
it's it's got to be better to get that
debt down
um but in the process I also found out
that he's maxed out his card so I'm
guessing we're somewhere around 30 or 40
000 in debt
okay so let's let's um
out just a little bit Paulie okay so you
are retired you said you are are you
pulling money from retirement everyone
you said you're making about half of
what you did or is that yeah in a pit
Okay so
um I'm making a 36.50 a month and
um
and how it brings in somewhere around
5500 a month and he brings in 5500 okay
um hey Polly before we get too deep into
like the Tactical what we do with the
money where your money goes are you
still spending on the cards
yeah yeah so
um it just seemed like every time I went
to use our so I have a separate account
because of uh something that happened in
2015 he thought he was going to leave so
we were separated for a while so I went
ahead and got my account for my own
safety to have money okay
um now we we still have a joint account
we're back together oh you know it's
good
um but uh he's not on the same page with
with the whole financial thing I think
he's still thinking you know he's
working full-time he's doing really well
he's you know
um but you're still spending on the card
too right like you said that you're
living I want you to cut those cards up
tonight like get your scissors out and
cut them up tonight
yeah because if we pay it off if we use
that eight thousand dollars and pay it
off and you're still spending we're
going to be in the same situation in six
months
yeah yeah absolutely
um so step one stop the bleeding
yeah exactly
um but that takes care of mine but not
his and
um I'm trying to get him on board and I
was hoping the Dave was there so you
could tell me how to talk to a man about
finances without them shutting down well
Rachel's pretty good about you know
couples and money yeah
um
okay so Paulie
um for you guys you do you still have a
separate accounts or are you guys
working out at the same account
well we have a joint account but
um that I have access to but then I have
a separate account and I've got a couple
thousand dollars saved but I'm gonna put
at least a thousand of it towards my
card
um I've rolled up all my change I've you
know I'm trying to sell things okay so
let me let me kind of pan let me pan up
I just want to get a full picture of you
guys as a couple so we'll we'll not
pretend that it's all separate so all
together you guys okay you so you're
making a little less than 10 grand a
month how much debt do you guys as a
couple have
I think it's going to be anywhere
between 30 and 40. I know mine is 19 and
I'm just guessing Okay yeah and that's
all on credit cards
yes okay do you have any cart do you
clean a camper
um our cars are all paid off right how
much how much is the camper
how much you have left to pay for it all
right two two or three I don't remember
what the payment is and I still need to
find out some information from him
because he does all the okay bills but
I've been trying to put together a
budget
um it was forty thousand dollars uh a
couple years ago so I imagine we're
paying at least a couple hundred on it
okay
um any other any other debt what do you
guys own your home
uh Wheels 411 and it goes anywhere
between 500 and 624 when you look at the
value online okay
but we've recently financed too many
times yep yep okay so here's the deal
Polly we are going to help you
tactically
um we're gonna give you Financial Peace
University we've been giving that away
all of this show but really if you can
get your husband you guys to do this
together these end lessons tactically
it's going to help you walk through all
of this but I think the I think one of
the bigger problems is is that you know
in a marriage if one person is trying to
you know fill in the whole of debt to
get a you know a a flat ground level uh
you know of trying to get out of this
financial hole but the other person is
digging at the bottom
then then yeah it's not going to work
right and that's why we really stress
for couples to work together so I know
that he's hesitant but there has to be
something in him Paulie that knows we're
not in a great situation my wife is
retired I'm coming up on retirement age
here in the next decade we still owe 411
000 on our house we are living paycheck
to paycheck we are depending on credit
cards we have we have forty thousand
dollars of credit card debt we have a
camper like all of this there is a level
to him that's going to feel that he
knows he knows I'm sure deep down and so
what you want you to talk about it and
that's it so that's that's where we
always say it's not just a money problem
there is a marriage issue that you guys
are not United and probably not just in
money and other things and so if you do
have a great
um Church in the area or a great
therapist marriage service I mean I'm
not kidding if there's any way to go and
get a third party involved this is the
time to do it because as you sitting
there trying to convince him may or may
not work I don't know I don't know your
marriage but I think unders for him to
know where you're at all you can do is
control you and Paulie I think it would
be a probably a helpful conversation and
a very maybe intimidating and vulnerable
conversation but to come to him and say
hey here are the numbers that I've seen
I've tried to pull you know what we have
and this is the situation
and I am scared I am freaked out I feel
like we should be further along than we
are at our age and I don't know what to
do and I I would love it and long for
you to come with me on this journey and
us do this together because I want our
future as a couple to be stress-free and
to be bright and to go and doing these
incredible things that we want to do at
retirement this is what we want to do
but I think what you're going to start
to find is that there's a lot of
marriage stuff under that that you guys
may need to heal from that 2015
situation that happens and I think
that's a great thing but starting out
this and opening the door when it comes
to money and that conversation I think
is really really important Polly but
well I think you need to take ownership
for your part in it you're not he's not
the only one digging this hole you're
digging it too and you need to stop with
a credit card and also just look at you
and what you can change